as a lot of you guys have probably
noticed already the tech space has been
a little bit dry lately in terms of new
products
so because of that there is a massive
amount of hype
around apple's upcoming m1x max which
are gonna be
the most significant mac products from
apple and
many many years due to them getting
completely redesigned
however this whole apple silicon
transition
probably couldn't have happened at a
worse time because the world is
currently going
through a massive chip shortage which is
impacting countless amounts of companies
and
in this video i'm gonna go through how
this chip shortage has already
impacted apple and how it's gonna affect
the upcoming m1x max as well the first
thing i want to talk about is how things
with apple have been
incredibly weird lately specifically
with a lot of leaks and rumors
many leakers like john prosser were 100
sure
that apple would be holding an event on
march 23rd
where they would release a bunch of new
products and kong
the most reliable apple leaker out there
with their almost perfect track record
also gave us the march 23rd date and as
we all know
the event that was supposed to be today
did not happen
and john prosser literally just shaved
his eyebrows
but besides that there are two theories
on why this would happen
number one is that apple never even
planned to have a march event in the
first place
and they simply put out fake news in an
attempt to weed out the internal sources
that are distributing these leaks so
instead of a march event
apple was planning to have an april
event all along
but personally i don't buy it at all
apple hasn't had an april event in
around 11
years so it just seems weird for apple
to plan it
this way from the very beginning now the
second theory is that apple
did plan to have a march event but they
had to cancel it for some unknown reason
putting it back an entire month and i
think that it's all due to the global
chip
shortage being much worse than many
companies anticipated
but before i get into explaining exactly
what's going on with the chip
shortage i want to point out a couple of
weird things
that apple has been doing last week
apple stopped production
of new imac pro models before officially
discontinuing it all together when the
existing supplies
ran out and then just yesterday apple
completely stopped selling the higher
end storage models
of their 21.5 inch imac which sort of
signals that apple is preparing to
replace it
with the rumored redesigned 24-inch imac
so with that there are a couple of
possibilities on why apple is doing this
the best case scenario is that apple is
literally going to release
a new 24 inch redesigned imac before the
end of this month
via a press release just like they did
with the ipad pro last year
and there's a small chance that it could
even happen as early as tomorrow
another scenario is that apple is
lowering the current imac stock
in preparation for an apple event next
month and the
absolute worst case scenario is this the
global silicon chip
shortage is so bad that they're delaying
everything because there literally
isn't enough chips out there for them to
handle the demand
from a new product release and this
could mean that the imacs
are unfortunately being delayed for
months so before i share my thoughts on
which one of these scenarios is most
likely to happen
as well as when we should be expecting
the m1x macbook pros
let me explain this whole global silicon
chip shortage thing
anything in this world with a chip in it
which is basically
all tech related hardware rely on
semiconductors
and most of them today are made out of
silicon wafers
which are then made into various
components that go
into every single tech product and the
problem is that the companies that are
making those silicon wafers and
semiconductors
are way behind and there are a couple of
different reasons for that
with the main one being of course the
pandemic
various factories around the world
producing semiconductor chips
had to temporarily close down because of
fears of the virus
spreading within the factories this
caused them to get
further and further behind on all of
their chip orders
at the same time the pandemic caused
demand for electronic devices to blow
up since everyone in the world had to
rely on technology
much more than they had to before with
many people also starting to work from
home
and on top of that people were also
starting to receive stimulus checks
and what better way to spend it than on
new tech related items
all of this combined caused a massive
spike in demand for
chips all while supply got hit
by some factories getting temporarily
closed down and
ever since then the demand has not
cooled down
in fact demand has increased due to the
price of bitcoin
increasing which in turn caused a huge
surge in demand
for graphics chips that can mine the
bitcoin
that's why all the new graphics cards
from amd and nvidia
have been selling out instantly and even
old graphics cards are
extremely overpriced due to low stock
and car makers have also been
experiencing massive chip shortages as
well
ford just announced that they're closing
down an entire factory in ohio
because of a lack of chips and last
month tesla shut down model 3 production
for two weeks
and mazda made production cuts as well
many companies
are cutting production and it looks like
this pain
is not going to end for months
potentially through the
end of the year so yeah a huge surge in
demand is causing a massive global chip
shortage
and this actually isn't the first time
this also happened back in 2010
due to a massive demand for smartphones
which is when they really started to
blow up and now with all of that said
and explained
let's discuss what's been going on with
apple and how this chip shortage is
going to affect
the release of the m1x max if we take a
look at the m1x 14 and 16 inch macbooks
we already know that apple has delayed
mass production of them
from may or june to sometime in the
second half of 2021 which begins in july
so we might not see them until sometime
this fall so as we can see
these shortages are already affecting
the m1x max
the only question that remains is what's
going on
with the redesigned imac john prosser
says that the imac is
ready to launch at any time and we
recently saw a leak of an
arm-based imac with thin x-code and
apple even confirmed
the existence of this arm-based machine
and the thing is
those leaks usually only come shortly
before an official release
and there's also the fact that apple
discontinued the larger storage
21.5 inch imac models which also
usually only happens right before the
launch of a new model
and to make it even more interesting we
also got leaks from multiple sources
pointing to a redesigned imac launching
in the first quarter of 2021
which ends on the last day of this month
so we could
actually be seeing a new imac getting
released before the end of this month
via a press release but on the other
hand
wouldn't apple want to show off the new
imac since it's getting its first
redesign in many many years so it's
definitely hard to speculate on when we
should expect it
but in my opinion i think there's a very
good chance that we'll be seeing it
before
the end of april but if that happens
keep in mind that it's very likely that
the base model is coming with the same
m1 ship that we already currently have
in the m1 max
now in terms of the future apple silicon
max being
impacted by the global chip shortage i
actually think that apple
is in the best possible position out of
any company out there
so let me explain why for most macs
apple currently relies on
intel for the cpu chips and amd for the
dedicated graphics chips
so any kind of shortages from those
companies
will directly impact apple max for
example
early last year apple refreshed the
13-inch macbook pros
giving the high-end model the brand new
10th gen chips from intel
but for some reason the base 1300 model
was stuck with the old 8th gen
chips even though it received some
upgrades
like getting the new magic keyboard and
the touch bar
only later was it revealed that the new
tension intel chips
had very low yields and that's why the
base model
stuck with the older hn chips but now
that apple is finally switching
to their own apple silicon they'll no
longer have to worry about
any chip shortages at those other
companies
since apple will also be using their own
graphics chips as well
apple will instead be relying on tsmc
the most advanced chip maker in the
world and since apple has such a good
relationship with them
they've been able to reserve their chip
production before
everybody else putting apple in the best
possible position
and on top of that tsmc is currently
working on building a massive new
facility
in arizona so apple has no worries on
that front either
the only thing apple has to worry about
is the supply of different components
like ram ssds and other general chips
which seem to be fine for now as far as
chip shortages are concerned but in
general
apple is in an extremely good spot now
that they're finally ditching intel and
amd
so the future of apple silicon max is
looking
very bright and hopefully we'll be
seeing that new redesigned imac
before the end of next month so there
you guys go hopefully you learned
something new from this video
and if you did go ahead and tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]